you cut your hair man you look different
i look better or worse
oh you look cute
and he's not as big as i expected him
you know what it's like dwayze in that
movie you know
you know geez you you're not that big
yeah piss me off and watch me grow you
know
but robin i love you i've been a big fan
of you uh
i'm a big fan thanks rowdy god bless you
you're still going by rowdy or
no rod roddy you know the rowdy was just
i never nothing was premeditated in my
career
i didn't come up with a name i came
fifth in the world playing the bagpipes
first time i fought professionally the
pipe band played me in the ring and my
first
name is roderick the announcer just knew
that he didn't know i was a substitute
he said ladies and gentlemen here comes
uh roddy the
the piper and the blood just got dropped
and
uh but you you in your new book you talk
about vince mcmahon in not a flattering
way
yeah i love to hate him you hate him no
i don't i don't hate him i don't hate
him all right so
the following are quotes from roddy on
vince mcmahon in the state of wrestling
all right i want to get wrestling back
on track what vince mcmahon forgets is
he didn't make wrestling his dad did
and that's true his father started the
whole you know wrestling business i
think maybe even his grandfather right
so what is it that he's doing wrong what
do you mean get back to you know
uh i don't i'm not a purist right i have
kids
i love my kids that's why i live for
them so you turn on the wrestling and
he's got the vince mcmahon kiss my ass
club
and as he pulls the back of his pants
down he wiggles his bum cheeks and he
says
look my ass even does tricks i thought
to myself oh i've known that for 30
years guy
oh yeah and then you know the thing was
no it's true what they're doing
so you hate the fact okay but but isn't
the wwf always about theatrics and isn't
about shocking and isn't it about uh
like but you're saying the story lines
used to be better more broad no
first of all there were no story lines
i've never had a storyline in my life
you never handed a script when you were
a wrestler there's one time
in the wcw a referee came with a fax to
me and said
you get into the ring the referee calls
us together
he gives instructions and rings the bell
what the hell did you think was going to
happen
until the bell rings i can't make no
money that was the only script that you
got i threw it back at the guy no
you know the art of wrestling is uh but
you always knew ahead of time who would
win
stuff the only thing that was known was
they wanted a common ending whatever
that was
how you got there that's the magic of
the rest that was up to you to be
spontaneous yeah that's where the improv
comes there's too much scripting and too
much acting
absolutely wrestling you know uh as in
new york said to me
when i did they live uh if you ever
thought wrestling was acting you're
wrong
yeah now why don't you start your own
wrestling what happened to you i mean
you were big in the right half
yeah i mean you were doing your own show
you had you had you were
you were like the kindest corner of
wrestling what happened
what happened was there a falling out
nah tell you what um
when wrestlemania 3 and the silver dome
93 000 people uh john carpenter asked me
to do the movie they live
and vince mcmahon jr got mad at me
because he said i'll have another movie
for you in four weeks i said now with
john carpenter directing it right
so he sent a message by my lawyer that
hulk hogan and vince mcmahon are the
only true
blue wwes the falling out really
occurred when you got offered your movie
and vin said to you don't do the movie
i'll put you in a movie yes because you
didn't comply with that yes sir you fell
out of favor
exactly and so therefore you become
persona non grata you can't come back to
the wwe
go away you know uh leave at your own
chosen speed but do a faster rod
did you say to listen vince i just want
to do the film i love the wwf i i want
to talk rationally here i don't want to
be out but he would not hear you
yes and also two or three days ago i
fedexed a book to vince
and as nice a letter as i could put
saying this to him
capsulized vince i don't want anything
from you your league
it's you're way off i got to make it
real clear you're playing that
i was the sickest of them all okay you
seem like a crazy guy
quite frankly i don't think it's an
accident
are you on any medication do you have to
take medicine no no no no you're not
going to take medicine
no i've done that one too i remember
there was a steroid uh
investigation and like you know you
admit to taking steroids right
sure yeah yeah of course i did yeah i
don't have any problem with it i
i don't know you know one of the things
the government used to do in those
steroid things
is testosterone they would put this does
not enhance athletic ability this is
your government jerking with the kids
well we knew it did so right away that
discredited anything the government ever
said
right then they took that label off it
and sir still trying to so you know
does it or does it not well now they say
it does so quit messing with it
you should be able to take it if it
doesn't enhance athletic ability
not well depending if you can't get a
heart on it or not you know with this
obviously
stop you from getting aroused uh no it
you know what gave me four kids
really absolutely testosterone
when you took steroids did your nuts get
smaller after the cycle
goes through a six-week cycle and the
stair the uh synthetic wears off your
nuts get smaller and you got to take a
thing called granada
grenada 12 and i think it's called it
switches out like a female hormone which
balances things back
right good tricky chemistry and you i
can even see in your wrist you broke
your wrist you won't have it fixed
because they say you won't be able to
play the bagpipes again
how did you know that i read your book
ah you did man yeah
honest to god if anybody's going to give
me an honest guy what did you think it's
really honest it's good
i did it for my memory and from my heart
so the point is when it comes to
wrestling vince mcmahon you'd like to
see a loosening up of the strings where
every word isn't scripted where where
vince isn't in charge of everything i
told you i sent vince a book and in the
note it says basically this
clean up the sexual part and i'll get
you right back on track with the
wrestling i don't have no problem with
you
if you don't then i officially declare
that wrestling is dead
you